the oregon health authority is pleased
to announce new guidelines well it's
pleased to announce that the cdc has
approved new guidelines for the
modernity booster are you ready
um
effective immediately adults who
received the moderna vaccine as part of
their primary series only have to wait
five months before getting a booster
only have to wait only have to wait
that's why we have to wait yay that is
the update that i was looking for
because i was just
chomping at the bit waiting for the
waiting waiting to be able to rush out
because that is definitely what everyone
wants when they get a vaccine how soon
can i get my next installment well so if
we were you know as long as we're just
idly wishing for wonderful things then
wouldn't it be great if we had a vaccine
that you only had to wait a week till
your next booster i think so i don't
want to have to wait five months that
seems like a long time in this month
waiting is not fun we all know that
waiting is hard
yes
no it's an amazing construction and you
can imagine that whoever came up with
that
you know they really
they earned six months worth of pay for
that
inversion of reality that they have now
perpetrated on the public in which time
they'll have to get two boosters
if they're even getting boosters i mean
i hate to be cynical but
at the oregon health authority i suspect
they are yeah the oregon hell they yeah
we're
remote enough from the centers of power
that they probably are yeah this is a
low financial incentive outpost out here
yes
um
okay
let's see oh i forgot uh when we were
talking about
that incredible testimony from
wilinsky and fauci
i wanted to point out this piece written
by a
friend of ours jimmy kim
in her substance let's be clear which is
called i was deceived about covet
vaccine safety
she starts by talking about having been
vaccinated
with the moderna vaccine in may of 2021
and then this is an incredibly long
article and is incredibly thorough and
first she defines consilience she
basically goes after
the um
she doesn't do this explicitly i think i
did read the whole article this morning
but it's very very long um i don't think
she goes after directly the argument
that um
that uh
uh tri critic trials um randomized
controllers control trials i was
thinking critical theory how could you
have forgotten randomized they are the
gold standard of everything critical
theory is also the gold standard yes it
is yeah so randomized control trials
being basically the standard of evidence
um
is uh is absurd and really what you're
hoping for is a lot of different kinds
of evidence pointing to the same thing
and you know rcts when done well
um do of course provide an overwhelming
amount of evidence but it's still one
fun signal when designed well and
executed well right
right but what they do what randomized
controlled trials do the reason that
there is even a basis for a claim that
they are the gold standard is that they
are very good at isolating
weak effects and making them visible
right by controlling for other all the
other things that might
lead you that might mislead you in this
direction right but i would also point
out that this is a classic
variant on the idea that science is
the strongest method we had have for
figuring out what is true but it is also
a fragile method it is vulnerable to
things like market forces it is not
robust to them and so randomized
controlled trials are very good at
finding a weak effect and making it
visible
but they are also
fantastically gameable yes that is to
say you can design trials to succeed and
you can design them to fail irrespective
of the thing that is being tested and
i know it's going to sound like i'm
becoming cynical but the more one digs
and the more one understands about the
way the pharma game is played the more
you realize that this idea that we all
carry that this is the gold standard may
indeed be about the fact that they are
gameable and therefore if you're a you
know a company that wishes to sell
compounds and get them inflicted on
patients then a gameable
mechanism a gameable metric is exactly
what you're looking for right especially
if you're allowed to stop them short
right the point is look we don't like it
this way we think that medicine is
science and medicine should be
scientific but the point is the idea
that this compound is effective at
limiting the harm of this disease that
is a narrative and the point is that
narrative is founded on what we think of
as evidence but if you have a gameable
kind of evidence then the point is oh i
can link this compound which i just so
happen to have a you know intellectual
property rights to to this disease which
i might broaden the definition of so
that more people appear to have it and
then wow boy a lot of this substance is
going to end up in a lot of those people
and a lot of cash is going to flow in
this other direction and the point is
well who amongst us really doesn't think
that those kinds of incentives and
opportunities are on the mind of these
corporations who do this yeah
we are all we are all privy uh to
falling prey to incentives all of us and
we all do fall prey to incentives and
pointing out incentives is not the same
thing as pointing out uh possibility of
conspiracy and also
um
those who point out incentives are thus
not inherently engaging in conspiracy
theory so jimmy um
lays out her case um again a very long
case and one which i think is eminently
shareable with those who are skeptical
of the position uh the vaccines may not
be all that they are cracked up to be if
you could show my screen here zach
um by saying
basically the conciliants that that
looking at multiple kinds of data and at
the point that they align concluding
something from them aligning
is a rather excellent way of assessing
vaccine safety here and she says i've
compiled multiple pieces of evidence to
argue that injuries from the code
vaccines are grossly underreported these
include one testimonies from doctors and
nurses two testimonies from the vaccine
injured three evidence from medical
records or official databases of adverse
events four evidence from the vaccine
trials themselves
five plausible mechanisms of action six
evidence from animal studies seven
evidence of past wrongdoing wrongdoing
by pharma eight evidence of corruption
or undue influence in our health
institutions
and bonus explanations for why we are
not hearing about this in the media each
section she continues of this article
could be its own book and indeed
she's got a ton of links in here but um
but it's not it's not even complete as
as will always be the case so i highly
recommend this as as basically a
clearing house of
arguments um and evidence um and
encourage you to to share it with people
who say what are you talking about of
course they're safe
so i would just add to this
we are all
built
to be logical
not to a fault right there are places
where logic will mislead you because you
don't have enough information so the
logical conclusion you reach is actually
less good than your intuitive conclusion
but we are all built to do logic because
it served our ancestors to deploy that
tool frequently especially when there's
something complex and difficult to
navigate
arrived because then you could you could
at least
uh try to parse out what was taking
place
but this gives you lots of kinds of
checks that you can do on whether
something makes sense right so one check
i often do
is
what would have to be true for this
thing that i think is true to actually
not be right
how like how robust is this piece of
information it's like the mirror image
of a prediction
right it it's a spot it is a prediction
but it's but it's not it's like a
negative prediction i think the the the
right um
the right analogy is it's a checksum
right you know
if you've got a program let's say you've
gotten a security-minded uh program
you've downloaded it from the internet
well how do you know that somebody
didn't give you
a version of the program in which
they've got a backdoor installed and
they just made the website look like the
real website and you downloaded a
program that isn't what you think it is
right well you can do a checksum right
which takes some set of things from
within the program that the originator
of the program uh built that if anybody
modified it wouldn't add to the same
number right and so the point is you can
say well i don't know why the thing i
downloaded doesn't match the thing that
uh the manufacturer is distributing but
i know i don't want to use it because
the checksum didn't match
um so anyway there are lots of things
you can check that way and this is just
kind of a checksum on isn't that a
little bit of a modern-day shiverless
it's like a technical yeah it's it's a
numer numerological which is wrong
because numerology is a weird something
but it's like a numeric it's a numeric
yeah and actually
this is this is no i think this is
really good because actually what it is
is um you know so for those of you who
don't know shibboleth is a biblical term
and the shibboleth is a shibboleth
shibboleth is a term that you could
pronounce various different ways but you
could recognize people who really were
part of your group because they would
pronounce it the same way and if they
pronounced it shiboleth or whatever the
alternatives would be you'd know
something was up you're not you're not
of us you're not with us but the thing
about a checksum or and i assume there
are other mechanisms that work like this
the thing about it is there are an
indefinitely large number of ways to be
wrong and only one to be right so it's
like a turbocharged kind of shibboleth
right yeah
i mean i think that's true for shivlas
too shabolis the shibalith you know
there's indefinite number of ways to say
it wrong or maybe it's not indefinite
it's not indefinite oh i see it
yeah it's more than one i see there's a
plurality but it's not indefinite yeah i
see the distinction
exactly um
you were going somewhere
i'm already here
i've been here since the beginning of
the podcast weren't you going somewhere
oh wasn't i going somewhere well i guess
what i was going to say is there are
lots of ways that you can kind of look
at a body of evidence and say does this
look like something somebody might have
constructed for my benefit so i reach a
wrong conclusion or does this look like
the way evidence actually works in the
world where
even if i come at it different ways i
come to the same place because it's
actually true yeah right yeah and that's
so powerful right if i think i know
something
and then i'm working on some other
problem and it leads me right back to
the same
deep truth it's like oh well now i have
two reasons to believe it not one
um yeah something's just cancelled yeah
right exactly so it's just a kind of
it's a kind of
uh isn't that that's just so rewarding
it's just like that's that's that's one
of the
that's one of the reasons to do it right
to do this kind of work is to end up
with things canceling and to be returned
back and go oh okay this does fit
absolutely
absolutely and it's a different kind of
reward to be like ah it doesn't fit
these are different things there's an
error somewhere i don't know where it is
yet
but
you know both of those have reward but
so we were headed to the hereticon
conference in miami we didn't get to go
because of uh because of our encounter
with covid but nonetheless one of the
things i wanted to do at hereticon which
is going to was going to involve a whole
you know audience full of very smart
people most of whom uh would not have
been deeply steeped in how to think
about uh covid or vaccine safety or
early treatment or anything
the thing i was going to say to them
which i should probably write up or
something
was
um
you
in the public i believe are subject to
an anamorphic illusion
anamorphic illusions are
you've all seen them you just don't know
the word probably like those chalk
drawings on sidewalks that look like a
giant chasm has opened up in the
sidewalk it's extremely compelling it's
very hard to convince your mind you're
not looking into a giant chasm but what
you may or may not realize is that it
looks like that from exactly one
location
right
and so
the exchange that the artist has made is
that from this vantage point i can make
a very compelling rendering of something
with a lot of 3d content you can look at
it from any other direction and then you
get some weirdly distorted thing that
doesn't that makes no sense
right it's incoherent it's at least
stretched and
it doesn't look like a 3d thing it looks
like a crazy thing
and my point to the audience was going
to be you are the subject of an
anamorphic illusion surrounding public
health and the only reason
that that's working is because you're
standing where they expect you
and the is your vantage point for just a
little right if you step three feet to
your right three feet to your left
you'll begin to see what we're talking
about if you continue to stand there
we're gonna sound crazy right right
um
so in any case i think what jimmy is up
to here is a very good indication of
look i believe something that yes you
will be told the public health officials
have ruled out long ago right
but
doesn't it look like a real object
because it doesn't you know look at all
these kinds of evidence right i might be
able to show you something a picture of
a rock and tell you all about it yeah
and somebody might challenge that it's
not what i say it is but it's different
than being able to hand you a rock and
you can look at it from any angle you
like and
but my you know but
my doctor said that he saw yeah that's
one doctor okay but ten doctors said
that they saw yeah but it's just doctors
okay but these people said that they
were injured okay but it's still just
people talking oh well we got medical
records and and there's oh well but
vares is flawed uh we got the vaccine
trials themselves oh
i don't know what i say about that we
got plausible mechanisms action animal
studies pastor giving by pharma evidence
of corruption she's got so many she's
just laid it out so cleanly all the
different kinds of evidence that we've
got
and um and it's and it's still not
complete right and so the point is what
would have to be true for the analysis
that she presents to just simply be
backwards right all of these things
would need a special explanation for
what had gone wrong and the point is you
can look at
what she says and you can say look i
don't have any ability to evaluate this
kind of evidence i know nothing about it
but then this other kind of evidence i
can evaluate so
maybe the one that i can't evaluate
she's wrong but if she's not wrong about
the one i can evaluate why do they point
in the same direction right right so
it's it's that style of how do you how
do you exactly how do you think in a
messy environment is this kind of the
thing which is why you and i always say
welcome to complex systems right yeah
it requires a different style of thought
and you know no surprise she's um i
actually don't know exactly her
background but she's trained as a
biologist
[Music]
you